et bien salut à tous les gamers et
gameuse c'est sciatique aujourd'hui on
se retrouve pour une vidéo très spécial
car il s'agit d'une vidéo comparatif
entre modern warfare 3 et battlefield 3
certes on dit souvent que ces deux jeux
ne sont pas comparables je suis d'accord
quand l'on parle du jean lui-même du
moins du gameplay car on s'est tout
simplement qu'aujourd'hui call of duty
est beaucoup plus fixés sur la guerre
arcade entre guillemets que battlefield
est plutôt fixe et énormément sur le
côté simulation de guerre ne s'en
plaindra pas car tout simplement cela
permet à tout le monde de trouver son
bonheur selon sa personnalité son style
de jeu mais bon pour revenir à 9 en
comparaison si nous réfléchissons dans
le fond nous pouvons tout de même
comparé des deux jeux sur certains
points et c'est ce que vous apercevrez
dans la vidéo alors voilà comment ça va
se dérouler tout simplement j'ai fait
appel à des youtuber connaisseurs est
inscrit dans la matière des deux fps
il ya d'un côté certains fans de call of
duty et d'autre de battlefield 3 ils
n'ont pas été choisies au hasard car je
les ai choisi par don tout simplement
car une sont ouverts d'esprit et peuvent
parler en toute sincérité et peuvent
être impartial j'ai donc choisi warteck
squeeze h1n1 virus et steve thompson 17
pour m'accompagner dans ce comparatif
ensuite à la fin de la vidéo vous aurez
le droit à des intervenants qui sont des
amis ou tout simplement des gens que
j'apprécie pour leur aisance vocale ou
leur aisance d'esprit où ils viendront
donner rapidement leur avis dans sa
globalité
sur ces deux fps et sur ce qu'ils ont
pensé de la vidéo en y donnant leurs
réactions aussi s'ils le souhaitent donc
en gros ce qui va se passer pour les
quatre youtuber qui m'accompagne je leur
ai posé cinq questions
cinq questions à laquelle ils auront
droit entre guillemets de données soit
1.1 modern warfare 3 ou soit 1 point à
battle filtre en finale de cette
question s'ils ne savent pas aussi le
but sur une des deux ou s'ils pensent
que les deux se valent
ils donneront 1,1 point à chacun des
deux jeux
au final il n'y aura une note sur 30 car
comme nous sommes cinq à répondre plus
un message de
conclusion au maximum il y aura 30
points pour un des jeux donc voilà je
crois que j'ai désormais fait le tour de
en général de ce que dispose la vidéo
est donc que désormais commencer donc
voilà je vous souhaite une agréable
vidéo
commençons tout de suite par la première
question
la première question est que pensez vous
de l'évolution actuelle de ces deux jeux
ou plus précisément pour vous lequel
s'est le plus clairement améliorée
depuis ses débuts en série tous les
gamers et warteck et aujourd'hui je suis
là pour répondre aux questions
concernant le débat entre battlefield 3
et modern en pha trois proposés par
ch'ti natif chroniqueurs c'est vraiment
un excellent boulot en nous proposant de
répondre à ces questions je vais essayer
de répondre aux questions a le plus
simplement et des mon avis le plus juste
voilà j'espère gommer réponses vont vous
plaire alors question numéro une du côté
graphique on est un peu tous les points
mais du côté graphique je pense que
battlefield 3 a une petite avance que
j'ai testé la démo je trouve que
graphiquement il est plus joli que le
moment je n'ai pas testé maintenant
d'entre eux trois mais je trouve que
graphiquement les bienvenus que
maintenant d'en faire 2 1 maintenant au
niveau dans la série call of duty ou du
graphisme de foncière eu d'énormes
évolution depuis call of duty 4
nous ça chauffe ça un peu dommage après
au niveau du gameplay c'est clair que
pour moi le call of duty pas un meilleur
gameplay jeu c'est vraiment quelque
chose de fluide pour moi battlefield 3
c'est un peu trop infiltration à mon
goût
donc je sais pas trop chez un peu
partagé pour cette question là je me
base plus sur le graphisme les
graphismes du jeu
je donnerai un point à battlefield 3
salut tout le monde je me présente je
suis h1n1 virus youtuber qui fait du
battlefield que ce soit pas de votre
compagnie 2 ou bac 2 le fil 3 et je suis
très heureux d'avoir été conviés par
cinématiques pour répondre à ces
questions donc je vais m'empresser tout
de suite d'y répondre
alors tout d'abord question
personnellement je pense que bon
certains sans doute rond se douteront de
mes réponses mais je pense que
battlefield 3 est par exemple au niveau
de l'évolution s'est améliorée parce que
dice nous a proposé electronic arts nous
ont proposé une version alpha une
version bêta et donc nous on demandé aux
joueurs de tester le jeu avant sa sortie
finale d'avoir la version finale du jeu
et je pense que ça a permis une une
meilleure finalisation du jeu
contrairement par exemple à call of duty
modern warfare 3 ou bien il n'y a eu
aucune version bêta et alpha alors on
avait un modern warfare 3 a pu être joué
à ou plus à plusieurs salons qui sont
déroulées comme le salon call of duty
élite call of duty xp excusez moi et et
plus récemment à la paris games week
donc mais c'est pas vraiment des
versions alpha et bêta pour corriger des
bugs et plutôt des sortes de preview de
jeux vidéo pour permettre aux fans de se
rendre dans ces salons
et de pouvoir y jouer tout simplement
[Musique]
bonjour à tous mon nom restait comme 117
propriétaire d'une nouvelle petite
chaîne 2000 et plus abonnés aujourd'hui
en votre présence pour répondre à la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
en civ mal en poule 3 au bâton sur 3 5
questions ont été posées pour répondre à
ce débat je vais les énumérer simplement
et répondre du mieux la question numéro
il faut voir plusieurs choses en compte
prendre plusieurs aspects rencontre
pardon pour essayer de cerner cette
question en général la première le
premier point qu'il faut voir si le
gameplay
lorsqu'un joueur de cor lorsqu'un joueur
pense aux joues à un call of duty
il sait automatiquement à quoi
s'attendre comme cause du tillay une
sauce qui est toujours resté l'âme qui
est toujours resté très similaires n'ont
pas la même mais très similaires la
raison à laquelle les jo et plus
particulièrement les sélections du
succès et lorsqu'un jeu d'un d'une série
à l'autre présente des améliorations et
non pas forcément des gros changements
d'un coup je pense que tout le monde a
appris sa leçon à la criée le lien chan
la raison pour laquelle les carreaux
vichy ont toujours eu du succès et que
le gameplay fondamentalement à la base
et le met dans les pattes en sciant dans
l'évolution du gameplay att très très
grande
une premier bâton criantes jusqu'à
battlefield 3 aujourd'hui jo ce point de
vue là je pense que ça peut décourager
certaines personnes et rendra
compréhension du jeu plus lent donc de
ce point de vue là lequel s'est
améliorée depuis ses débuts j'ai envie
de dire bâton field
mais lequel est le plus attrayant j'ai
envie de dire d'en douter
yo tout le monde c'est lucas aya squeeze
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas alors
aujourd'hui je vous retrouve pour
répondre à 5 questions que steen atik
m'imposer et franchement je vais mettre
du coeur car je trouve que c'est un
sujet très intéressant mais qui peut
portis puis confié je suis tendu en dix
ans a enfin moi j'ai essayé de rester
assez sérieux car on n'est pas là pour
rigoler donc la première question moi
personnellement je pense que les deux
jeux se sont grandement améliorées
depuis
depuis leurs débuts ça c'est quelque
chose de clair et net notamment bas pour
call of duty ou la personnalisation a
été quand même comme des choses de très
nouveau lors de code cats on peut on
peut vraiment personnaliser ses classes
et toussa toussa
donc bon au niveau de l'évolution du
gameplay on peut pas tellement évolué
que ça ça reste un fps de type arcade
pour call of duty est de type plus axé
simulation pour battlefield 3 mais ça
reste quand même de l'arcal car un jeu
de simulation nombreux vip a enfin bon
et donc pas personnellement je pense
qu'ils les deux joueurs ont bien évolué
tous les deux notamment avec battlefield
3 ils ont évolué surtout graphiquement
puisqu'il pouvait pas apporter grand
chose au niveau du gameplay donc ils ont
mis le paquet sur les graphismes et on
s'en prend plein la vue en jouant haut
niveau de call of duty c'est un peu
pareil n'ont pas pu ils n'ont pas pu
faire quelque chose de nouveau au niveau
du gameplay donc si ils nous ont proposé
quelque chose de nouveau au niveau de la
personnalisation des personnages donc
lors de black ops par exemple par la
personnalisation tout court des armes et
tout ça et puis donc bah bah voilà donc
y en a un qui a évolué graphiquement et
l'autre qui a plus évolué audit ou
comment dire de là
de la personnalisation du personnage et
de la personnalisation de larmes voilà
nos pour ma part je pense que les deux
jeux ou quand même vraiment beaucoup
évolué depuis les tout premiers opus et
je peux vous dire que que ça se voit
[Musique]
moins pour moi pour moi les deux jeux
c'est vrai que clairement de l'epr jo
notices sont forcément tous les deux
amélioré car à l'évolution du jeu vidéo
fait que ça s'améliore après tout
simplement au niveau des deux des deux
plateformes cela que l'un des deux jeux
plutôt pardon c'est vrai que battlefield
et même un petit avantage qui servent à
dire améliorer sur ce battlefield 3 avec
leur nouveau moteur graphique leur
frosbite 2 c'est vrai que ça les a aidés
entre guillemets pour faire de très
belles vidéos de campagne publicitaire
mais bon ça sort pour notre question en
tout cas c'est vrai que pour - à mon
avis les deux se vaut tout simplement
parce que c'est vrai que call of duty
c'est très très inspiré aussi de ce que
faisait les autres c'est les autres
firmes donc tout simplement vision
devient réfléchissons bien travaillé ko
au niveau graphique mais ils sont restés
un petit peu sur une affaire qui roule
des affaires qui marchent parce que
c'est vrai que ont pratiquement faire
trois passes que
ça va pas changer au niveau graphique ce
qui est vrai mais en même temps il y
avait du coup beaucoup de gens qui
disaient voir à la sortie modern warfare
2 waouh c'est exceptionnel savait
presque révolutionner le fps était
vraiment très très beaux modèles enfin
de nous tous les français en tout cas
mais me et c'est vrai que après tout
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait activision
sont dit tiens avec l'équipe de la pièce
voire plus que moulins fin 2 c'est un
marché à fond à fond ben on va faire un
petit mot des renforts 3 pas et avec les
améliorations on va rester sur le même
graphisme puisque tout le monde avait
aimé et puis d'un autre côté il ya
battlefield et à battlefield qui équipes
de dice etc qui se sont dits maintien
nous on va on va s'améliorer côté
graphique ont rapporté quelque chose en
main devant nouveau enfin de nouveaux
plus tôt et pour mettre plein la vue
pour essayer de concurrencer cette firme
qui est comme call of duty une grosse
firme voilà avec leur pub ça a été
vraiment quelque chose qui est un petit
peu entré dans les moeurs du fps qu'ils
ont voulu apporter ce côté graphique qui
s'améliorait avec les années c'est vrai
que sur ça c'est un gros point fort
qu'ils ont importé pour ce c'est vrai
que le jeu est magnifique
ensuite pour leurs campagnes sur loup
leur campagne solo qui est vraiment
réputé pour être très explosif moi j'ai
pas vraiment aimé c'est de battlefield
bad company 2 même s'ils n'ont ensemble
bateau file d'autres compagnies 1 et les
correct même si on sait que battlefield
est différent de bonne compagnie mais
c'est vrai que dans l'ensemble c'est
quand même du lourd et c'est quand même
autre chose
donc pour moi les deux se sont
clairement améliorées dans deux points
différents donc parallèles l'une d'entre
elles mais ce sont vraiment très très
bien d'améliorer donc pour moi c'est un
peu chacun voilà
deuxième question qu'elle est du jeu qui
devrait
le plus vendu selon
alors ce
je pense que ça va être modern warfare 3
pour la simple et bonne raison que déjà
toute la campagne publicitaire qu'il ya
autour de modern warfare 3 est juste
énorme et également tout simplement tous
les joueurs de fps connaissent la série
call of duty mais également un petit
bémol je trouve pour battlefield qui que
qu'ils n'ont pas fait modern warfare 3
c'est de sortir une bêta parce que tout
simplement moi j'ai testé la beta et je
vais pas acheter le jeu tu veux pas
acheter parce que je suis trop il y
aurait peut-être pas une bêta j'aurais
peut-être tester acheté le jeu donc je
pense clairement que c'est vrai que mon
danseur 3 pour cette question alors
selon moi le jeu qui devrait être le
plus vendu c'est battlefield 3
parce que tout simplement il ya eu
beaucoup plus d'évolution que ce soit au
niveau du gameplay au niveau 2 des
graphismes et tout ça dans ce
battlefield
contrairement à call of duty ou le jeu
restera à peu près similaire alors bon
les développeurs ont corriger ce qui
n'allait pas dans call of duty modern
warfare 2 mais à mon avis par exemple le
fait que l'ump 45 soit un petit peu un
petit peu over puissante ça aurait pu
être corrigé pendant que le jeu pendant
que le jeu était sorti il aurait pu
faire des patchs pour pour nerf et
larmes pour la rendre moins puissante
donc voilà je pense que battlefield 3
alors au niveau des chiffres il me
semble que ça sera call of duty le plus
vendu mais je trouve ça un petit peu
dommage je pense que battlefield 3
mérite amplement d'atteindre d'attendre
le succès d'un call of duty et donc
voilà selon moi en fait surprendre
l'aspect numéro un en compte qui est
quel est l'objectif derrière ces jeux
l'objectif très clair derrière quand ce
doute y est que cette série est une
machine à fric c'est une machine à
imprimer les dollar cotant que ce soit
les dlc que le jeu en tant que tel
là où l'esprit de battre au filet
beaucoup plus léger et les développeurs
ont bien plus grande écoute de la
communauté donc selon moi je lui dise
que j'ai envie de dire ses limites de
l'aqrp allende mais j'ai envie de dire
bâton sur trois devraient être plus
vendus pour le simple fait que les
développeurs ont en quelque chose à
[ __ ] que leur audience
la aux cordes de kate une machine à fric
c'est un jeu par an c'est payé 70 de
large le jeu est ensuite allé payer 65
pour les map pack
c'est un esprit très malsain et je pense
que c'est pour ça que ma tension 3
devrait être plus vendre
moi personnellement je pense que pour
cette question je pense qu'on peut pas
tout de suite juger étant donné qu'on
n'a pas testé modern warfare 3 de fond
en comble comme on est actuellement tous
en train geek et comme des gros porcs
sur battlefield 3 donc je pense
personnellement que bon pour le moment
étant donné que j'ai vu que battlefield
3 et que j'ai joué vraiment que 5
minutes 10 minutes à la paris games week
hamouda renfort 3 je peux pas juger
modérera par trois sur un simple petit
gameplay de dix minutes donc écoutez je
pense que les deux jeux de toute façon
mériteront là autant que l'autre d'être
vendus ne serait-ce pour l'évolution des
graphismes de battlefield 3 est
l'invention d'un nouveau mode mode
survival de modern warfare 3 donc je
pense qu'au niveau des ventes ça devrait
être équitable
enfin j'aimerais que ce soit équitable
car les deux des deux développeurs
veulent le mérite voilà tout simplement
comme le dit squeeze c'est vrai que on
aimerait que les deux soient le plus
vendu tout simplement que les deux
soient autant vendu un clope ce c'est
vrai qu ils se sont quand même amélioré
2 vraiment grandement et ils proposent
de deux choses différentes qui sont
quand même pas mal chacun de son côté
mais je sais que ce sera à call of duty
modern warfare 3 qui va être le plus en
vue qui à l'ampleur que ça a pris depuis
toutes ces années cette firme call of
duty est tellement énorme qu'elle est
quasiment on va dire imbattable ça peut
être dommage comme ça peut être bien
mais bon activités en tout cas super
heureux pour ça mais c'est vrai que tout
simplement une offre à call of duty pour
moi qui va s'en [ __ ] plein les poches
c'est qui qui veut qui va vendre le plus
de jeu que ce serait call of duty modern
fort 3 dont voire troisième question est
ce que la campagne publicitaire du call
of duty modern warfare 3 était selon
vous plus aboutie que celle de
battlefield 3
j'ai un peu répondez à cette question
dans la question 2 mais je pense enfin
la campagne des deux a été pas mal on
dire développer des deux côtés mais
c'est clair que voilà
la campagne publicitaire de coller
multirisques quand même quelque chose de
plus énorme même rapport au niveau de la
proposition n'est des packs plus plus
cher avec des meilleures fins élégants
d'acheter le jeu vous passez juste le
jeu y rester un mois je pense que au
niveau de la campagne publicitaire c'est
modern warfare 3 qui remporte au niveau
des campagnes publicitaires je pense que
call of duty modern warfare 3 était au
dessus au niveau des affichages publics
c'est à dire qu'on voyait pour plus d'
affiches de modern warfare 3 dans la rue
que des affiches de battlefield 3 par
contre au niveau des traileurs j'ai
toujours trouvé les trailer de modern
warfare 3 assez fades comparés à ces de
battlefield 3 bat déjà tout simplement
parce que le moteur graphique de
battlefield 3 pouvait beaucoup plus
s'afficher parce que c'est un nouveau
c'est un nouveau moteur graphique tout
simplement
alors que celui de call of duty modern
warfare 3 date déjà d'il ya un bon
moment donc à ce niveau là je pense que
modern warfare 3 comme je l'aï dit tout
à l'heure dans la rue étaient beaucoup
plus visible par contre sur internet et
et au niveau de youtube et tout ça
battlefield 3 en voyez beaucoup plus
envoyer beaucoup plus du pâté je ne
considère pas la campagne de
concernant ballon sur le 3 comme étant
un jeu qui a reçu une campagne
publicitaire mais plutôt harcèlement
publicitaire où que l'on aille sur
youtube et quoi qu'on fasse on entend en
permanence par les deux bateaux sur
trois seba tension trois bateaux que 304
et lorsqu'on parle de corps ou du team
annonce l'octroi à chaque fois c'est
pour dire oh mon dieu ce jeu ressemble
tellement au précédent un ballon à
refaire je ne devrais pas l'acheter
pouces rouge pouces roja qu'est ce que
c'est que cette connerie
la campagne publicitaire de balancier 3
est beaucoup plus profonde a reçu
beaucoup plus d'investissement sur moi
au niveau monétaire tout simplement
dice et ses millions de dollars en
publicité ont su convaincre pas mal de
gens je pense que cette demande en fait
3 s'adresse à un public plus habitué au
corps duty plus et groupe et j'ai envie
d'y aller comprennent mieux leur
audience pour battant sion 2-3 il est
clair que cette série a eu beaucoup plus
de publicité mais non en fait 3 oui
c'est clair
attention 3 et le plus de publicité mais
ce n'était pas une publicité pour les
amis alors au niveau des campagnes
publicitaires ils ont tous les deux mis
le paquet c'est dire qu'on s'en prend
plein la vue pour entreprendre les
trailer on voit les gameplay tout ça on
se prend vraiment plein la vue dans les
deux cas je pense que les trailer de
battlefield 3 sont enfin le concert la
campagne j'espère battlefield 3 est plus
impressionnante puisque étant donné
qu'on voit juste des des mini morceaux
de gameplay on remarque juste les
graphismes et du coup c'est ça pour nous
quand on voit les trailer qui nous
marquent donc je pense que du coup ça
donne est bien plus envie d'acheter
battlefield 3 que mme oda fatras parce
que là encore trop c'était à peu près
les mêmes graphismes et on voyait juste
quelques extraits du mode survival au
niveau des vrais trailer après c'est
clair que notamment sur code qg quand on
voit les trailer qui sont vachement long
et tout ça on peut on peut enfin je sais
pas trop comment m'y remets d'ailleurs
je ne répond absolument pas la question
à l'heure actuelle non mais bon pour moi
au niveau de la campagne publicitaire il
n'y en a pas une qui est plus abouti que
l'autre les deux étaient au même stade
d'ailleurs à chaque fois on voyait
autant moderator 3 partout que
battlefield 3
donc je pense que nos gars tu sais que
c'était que ce qu'est ce que c'est que
ce qu'est ce que c'était que ce bruit
donc fausse que n'ya pas y'a pas de
campagne publicitaire qui épisodes
mythiques que l'autre je pense que ça
peu près la même chose pour moi la
campagne de pub de mode en fort 3 tout
simplement je pense que je vais pencher
plus dans la vie de mort tech tout
simplement que c'est vrai qu'ils nous
ont proposé quelque chose de vraiment
très lourd et assez tôt donc voir monter
buzz des boues spot publicitaire de
l'affichage un petit peu partout bon
après c'est vrai que là je parle qu'au
niveau de la france parce que niveau des
autres pays c'est vrai que ça change et
un ami qui est parti en voyage en
angleterre
karine dubois qui m'a dit waouh un truc
de fou à londres c'est battlefield
battlefield tel fils votre feed en a
partout de ce fichage est une limite
quel but inexistant mais c'est vrai
qu'on france c'était plutôt le côté
inverse s'est vendu moon of war iii
convoyer vraiment beaucoup c'est vrai
que comme dit aussi chan un virus sur
internet on voyait beaucoup du
battlefield c'est vrai qu'ils ont eu non
plus jouer cette carte-là de l'internet
mais sinon je pense que ça se vaut car
au final juste à la proche de la sortie
de battlefield
on voyait comme un petit peu plus moi
qui a été à la paris games week
je voyais tout le temps du mot des
renforts 3 et puis là je suis arrivé je
suis j'ai pris le train pour aller à
paris en voiture c'est la misère même si
j'habite pas loin mais bon pour aller
non pas qu'ils sont bons je raconte un
peu ma vie mais en prenant train l'aï
regardé il y avait des crozes affiche
paris games week avec battlefield
battlefield on envoyer beaucoup après
c'est vrai que vous allez entreprendre
de versailles je voyais beaucoup de
battlefield mais sinon c'est vrai que
modern war iii ont vraiment il était
présent dès le début mais battlefield
sur la fin au fond c'est vraiment bien
attrapés et puis vu qui c'était aussi
sur internet à se répandre
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment un outil
indispensable c'est vrai que moi je
pense que les deux se vaut les deux se
vaut donc ce sera plus un pouce un point
tchèque voit la quatrième question selon
vous lequel des deux jeux représentent
vraiment un jeu d'équipé et comment
trouvez vous les deux communautés pour
la question des jeux d'équipé c'est
battlefield 3 clairement c'est vraiment
un jeu où moi je partirai pas en ligne
tout seul sur battlefield 3 quoi
franchement je préfèrerais vendre quitte
escouade partir sur les objectifs est
tous vraiment c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment un jeu d'équipé après sur call
of duty
franchement sans souci je partirai faire
une petite guerre terrestre ou une
petite mêlée générale tout seul avec un
sniper au niveau de la communauté
comment dire je trouve que battle fixé
en moins jeu au c'est vraiment réaliste
c'est la guerre quoi c'est pas un jeu
d'arcade collodi
c'est la guerre et voilà la communauté
qui est sur battlefield et la communauté
juste après la communauté de call of
duty ya de très bons joueurs partout il
ya aussi d'autres joueurs
malheureusement tout le monde connaît
youtube tout le monde tenait un peu tous
ces trucs qui nous font un peu rage et
c'est là voilà les communautés sont
partagés c'est juste croit la légende ou
de la manière qu'ils veulent mais ces
terres que au niveau de la communauté je
pense que à la communauté de battlefield
est plus adapté au type de jeu
je pense que les deux communautés entre
les deux jeux se valent dans le sens où
j'ai été très déçu de la communauté
battlefield récemment j'ai vu beaucoup
de membres de la communauté battlefield
à les insulter et trolls et les joueurs
call of duty
sans aucune raison valable juste pour
faire chier le monde donc à ce niveau là
j'étais très déçu de cette communauté
après la communauté call of duty a aussi
eu sa période de troll intensifs et d'
insulte facile en faire la communauté
battlefield il n'empêche que
heureusement qu'il ya des gens super
sympa dans les deux communautés
ce qui fait que c'est ça reste quand
même un énorme plaisir de jouer à call
of duty ou abf ou à battlefield parce
que je suis vraiment fan des deux je
sais juste que voilà call of duty depuis
blackos m'a un petit peu déçu donc en ce
moment je suis beaucoup plus sur
battlefield
mais je garde quand même un certain
plaisir on va dire un plaisir conséquent
à jouer à call of duty 4 ou ou même call
of duty 5
donc voila et puis au niveau du jeu
d'équipé je pense que battlefield 3 sera
un petit peu plus tactique dans le sens
où il faudra faire beaucoup plus
attention à nos déplacements et tout ça
mais call of duty reste quand même un
jeu plus facilement jouable en à mon
avis en compétition un peu pro donc moi
je pense qu'il faut quand même attendre
la sortie de modern warfare 3 pour se
faire une véritable idée de cet esprit
de jeu décrypte tout simplement
et puis voilà passons à la dernière
question en matière de jeu d'équipé
étant un très ancien joueur de xbox je
dirais et ça c'est purement d'opinion
certains sont d'accord d'autres noms que
le seul bon jeune équipe femme lit seul
montre l'équipe son réseau et ghislain
voile vous avez droit d'être en
désaccord il est vrai que bâton sur des
teintes d'excellents jeunes équipes
quant aux duty n'est pas tant un jeu
d'équipé mais un jeu de coordination à
savoir que s'il joue à un mode à
objectifs avec nom de tous les
coéquipiers avec qui nous devons
communiquer et tenté de jouer l'objectif
c'était pas tant au travail des équipes
mais à la coordination à savoir que
chaque joueur devra savoir exactement
quelle est sa tâche dans la partie et
comment la réaliser le mieux possible
pour faire ça le meilleur moyen est tout
simplement de savoir exactement qu'est
ce que vous voulez faire dans votre
parti lahood en battant 6-1 en fait
l'une des techniques ne l'utilisent que
l'on a encore englouti c'est simplement
d'avoir une leader dans chaque partie on
va dire que je fais de la domination est
bien le leader sur notre groupe d'amis
donc les six personnes avec qui on sera
solidaire s'occupera de dire un prenez
tel drapeau allez planter une bombe à
tel endroit etc etc
dans battlefield fonctionnant en mode
high squad
on ne peut pas remplir toutes les espada
fin du mois sur consoles sur pc c'est
autre chose
son console il est très dur en fait non
je pense même pas qu'il soit possible de
remplir toutes les escouades dans une
partie tout simplement parce que les
communications le système de
communication ne l'est pas le faire donc
je pense que de ce point de vue là au
niveau communication malheureusement
valenciennes 3 est plus restreint je
pense qu'au niveau du travail et qui
prohibe attention 3 est un jeu de
travail d'équipé c'est clair surtout
dans les mandats objectifs mêmes l'edf
match enfin le match à mort par équipe
il faut absolument communiquer avec les
personnes faire ce qu'ils appellent des
cravates c'est à dire donner des
indications en permanence il travaille
en équipe donc je dirai au niveau du
travail d'équipé battlefield 3 au niveau
de la coordination temps utile alors là
on va pas se voiler la face devant ça
sert à rien de se voiler la face
bon disons que les au niveau des deux
communautés
il ya environ la moitié voire plus des
jeux battlefield 3 voir tous les joueurs
battlefield 3 qui jouent à call of duty
et enfin une bonne partie d'entre eux en
tout cas et pagis versa de ski au
derrière par trois il ya moins joueur de
l'as far 3 qui joua à battlefield 3 que
y en a 2 battle cry 3 que je un moteur
1.3 tout simplement
on va comment vous dire disons que sur
battlefield 3 enfin je vous dis cela
parce que du coup ça influence sur la
communauté c'est à dire que sur
battlefield 3 d'ailleurs c'est une
question très intéressante
on est en quelque sorte obligé de jouer
en équipe puisque on est dans des
véhicules
on peut prendre des véhicules donc par
exemple je prends l'exemple du dutronc
decoster transporter où on a deux
mitrailleur sur les côtés imaginons par
exemple que on est un mitrailleur
seulement à droite et ben il faut voler
tout ça en fonction du métreur à droite
il faut lui marqué par exemple dans le
chat au but durant micro pour les
joueurs console sur la droite en queue
et demi à 12h enfin ou quoi ou des trucs
comme ça
d'ailleurs à droite unie à 12 enfants
bas c'est complètement débile mais en
tout cas je pense que oui c'est clair
que il faut plus joué en équipe dans
battlefield 3 parce qu'il faut plus être
coordonnés au niveau des mouvements
étant donné qu'il faut attaquer des
points que l'amap est bien plus grande
que si on attaque par mini vague chaque
point ça sert strictement à rien donc je
pense que oui le jeu d'équipé et intérêt
à être plus approfondie d'un bateau
depuis trois étant donné que dans lequel
duty modern warfare 3 voilà bon grosso
modo ça serait un peu comme w2 c'est un
peu chacun pour soi mais pas tant que ça
mille de rien quand il faut mine de rien
et c'est de prendre les points avec ses
allées tout ça mais bon quand même ne
serait ce que par la présence de
véhicules dans battlefield 3 c'est
battlefield 3 qui l'emportent sur ce
point là où il ya le meilleur jeu
d'équipé voilà
alors pour moi c'est clairement
battlefield 3 qui représente là même la
pinière battlefield que représente
vraiment le côté jeu d'équipé
car presque entre guillemets un peu
forcée par le jeu à jouer en équipe bon
après moi je suis très spécialisés jouer
à battlefield bad company à battlefield
tout court et c'est vrai que moi je joue
souvent en mode ruée quasiment qu'à ça
donc on s'est vraiment le mode par
excellence où on joue en équipe pardon
mais c'est vrai qu'on a un petit peu
contraints par le jeu mais bon c'est pas
plus mal car moi j'aime ce côté des deux
équipes
moi personnellement quand je me suis
souvent au même quasiment tout le temps
mais tin et c'est vrai que ranimer des
mes collègues d'actes aguilera nîmes ça
me fait gagner des points donc en fait
entre guillemets c'est ce qui est un
petit peu de donne envie de jouer en
équipe
tu vois ton collègues à terre j'en suis
sûr qu'on gagnera pas de points il y
aura beaucoup d'enfants et qui serait là
ils feraient ouais ben non je te ranime
passé alors pas en vrai maintenant comme
on gagne des points là je vais leur
animés par le même genre admis en
réanimation deux trois quatre d'affilée
je gagne plein de points puis ça me fait
monter dans mes statistiques au niveau
du classement
donc c'est un petit peu contraint par
pro gameplay du jeu de l'équipe mais
c'est pas plus mal comme outil car moi
j'aime bien ce système on s'aide c'est
vrai que clairement j'ai pas totalement
testé pour affiner
modern war 3 pour donner un gros avis
sur ça mais d'après ce que je pense me
des renforts 3 s'est amélioré je me
proposais des jo il favorise les douars
qui joue l'objectif est qu'ils jouent en
équipe dans la filière modèle phare donc
enfin pour mot des renforts 3 quoi donc
j'espère que ce sera vraiment c'est donc
moi j'attends de voir mais sinon oui sur
le coup au jour d'aujourd'hui ou à leur
compte pas vexer vraiment battlefield tu
représentes le jeu de l'équipe
voilà
cinquième et dernière question selon
vous le fait qu'activision fasse payer
tout ce qu'ils proposent dlc côté l'ip
est votre petit lui jouer un mauvais
tour comparé à battlefield 3 qui lui
propose plus de contenu gratuit de son
côté alors c'est vrai que à ce niveau là
outre colossiens abusent un petit peu
sur les contenus téléchargeables
c'est vrai que l on paye un jeu bien
plus le mien plus que le prix qui
devrait être avec tous ces
téléchargements un bon exemple avec
black hole c'est tous ces décès de deux
maps zombies et autres
après c'est la voilà le contenu donc moi
moi je fais des études de game design
j'apprends a créé justement un peu
dénudée monde comme ça et je en fait et
honnêtement je comprends qu'ils
proposent c'est vrai ce contenu payant
parce que c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose d'assez difficile à réaliser et je
peux comprendre
maintenant c'est clair voilà battlefield
remporte sur le fait qu'ils ont plus de
plus c'est gratuit à proposer plus
davantage à ce niveau là mais voilà
depuis call of duty black ops
d'activision s'en mettre plein les
poches tout simplement ils ont sorti
énormément dlc et c'est vraiment très
triste pour la pour la communauté parce
que les modders ne peuvent plus se faire
plaisir et essayer de créer des
nouvelles maps et tout ça tout
simplement parce que c'est tout
simplement parce que le système est
complètement bloquée et j'ai envie de
dire un petit peu pourrie par les dlc
donc je pense que le fait qu'activision
fasse payer un service comme call of
duty élite 50 euros l'année alors qu'ils
font déjà payer le jeu entre 50 et 70
euros pour pourvoir un tifo large je
pense que c'est clairement de l'arnaqué
que ça a déçu beaucoup de joueurs et je
pense qu'ils ont perdu des ventes à ce
niveau là par contre
battlefield 3 il a eu un système de
précommande qui faisait que
on avait du contenu exclusif
gratuitement s'ils ont précommandé le
jeu ce qui fait que pour moi la balle à
plat la politique publicitaire et au
niveau des dlc la politique comment je
pourrais dire dlc yens 2 d'electronic
arts s'est beaucoup moins agressive et
pour l'instant j'espère qu'ils vont pas
trop tomber dans le l'esprit de l'argent
facile toujours est il qu'il ya quand
même un truc qui m'a énormément déçu sur
battlefield 3 c'est que lorsqu'on est
sur consoles on est obligé de racheter
une sorte de passe à dix euros si par
exemple on prête son cd jeux un copain
c'est à dire que vous inscrivez un
compte et si quelqu'un d'autre veut
jouer à battlefield 3 ans multiplayer il
sera obligé de racheter un
une sorte de passe à dix euros et ça
pourrit complètement le système le
marché d'occasion de ce jeu et voilà
c'est dans les deux côtés il n'y a pas
que des bons points donc ça c'est triste
de voir les entreprises un peu tourné
comme ça mais bon on peut on est obligé
de subir donc voilà selon vous le fait
qu'activision fasse payer tout ce qu'il
propose d elle c est qu on dit chez
élite peut-il jouer un mauvais tour
comparé à battlefield 3 qui propose plus
de contenu gratuit
alors ceci me fait retourner à la
question numéro 1 ou 2 ou plus certains
qui est la mentalité derrière les jeux
je pense que oui le fait que les jeunes
fassent payer principalement tout ce
qu'ils ont à offrir
chose qu'ils ont à vendre lui à leur
réputation du mit a au bout des joueurs
que les jours toute la nuit à les styles
que les gens ou pour la série il est
clair que safari l'image que là ce que
le joueur a de la série et oui je pense
que ça peut lui nous un mauvais tour
d'un autre côté ba social phrase ne
propose pas énormément de peau plus
gratuit les compagnies que j'ai vu
qu'ils offrent le plus de compagnie
pendant le dlc gratuits sont bonne vie
et il parle va je vous rappelle qu'il a
fait team paul crise qui a fait au total
a fait 15e strike ce qui est phénoménal
de valve s'est séparé cependant
rappelons mais je vais d'abord écrire
dessus va vous imaginez ce qui est
incroyable c'est que il faut un jeu team
fortress 2 par exemple à qu'ils publient
que par la suite il donne gratuitement
et qu'il continue à mettre à jour
pendant des années ça c'est énorme
bref je reviens battant sur trois oui je
pense que ça peut augmenter la
réputation bateau sur trois ils lui et
donner une meilleure apparence au niveau
des joueurs là où faire le fait
qu'activer une face tous payés oui ça
leur fait descendre leur réputation
je ne pense pas que cela en veut pas
jouer un mauvais tour étant donné que
malheureusement les gens se plaignent du
prix des dlc ce prêt se plaignent du
prix du jeu mais l'achète quand même moi
mon opinion et si jamais vous trouvez
qu'un développeur vous à abuser de votre
confiance loi a eu des comportements
envers vous qui vous
ne semble pas acceptable cesser de
supporter ce développeur nom ne
l'encouragé pas n'achetez pas leur dlc
n'achetez pas tout le contenu qu'ils ont
à proposer
et même si c'est des trucs ridicules du
genre à carmaux pour enfin camouflage
pour une arme comme il fonde un gain de
0,3 ne l'achetez pas d'encourager pas
développeur d'encourager pas ses actions
prenez le jeu en tant que tel mais les
mapaq tout ce qui pourrait être payant
en extra ne le prenez pas si vous en
avez envie bien sûr si vous jugez que
htc dlc peut améliorer votre expérience
de jeu dans ce cas c'est totalement
libre à vous mais n'allez pas vous
plaindre du prix des dlc et ensuite pour
les acheter donc voila c'était à peu
près tout ce que j'avais à dire et
maintenant probablement la question la
plus intéressante de tout ce petit
questionnaire que steen atik mike leigh
donc selon vous le fait qu'activision
fasse payer tout ce qu'ils proposent des
hells échos les litiges lui jouer un
mauvais tour comparé à battlefield 3 qui
propose plus de contenus gratuits et
bien la réponse est non selon moi tout
simplement parce que les joueurs de call
of duty achèteront call of
et si les dlc et qu'on a dit ça y est
enfin ce n'est pas une obligation donc
au pire ils les joueurs dont nous
n'aurons rien à faire strictement rien à
faire et je romps homo narrans faire 3
de base sans les extorsions et tout ça
donc je pense que quand les gens
achètent me donnera 3 c'est pour jouer à
me raffin trois ils se fichent de des
extensions qui a des atouts ça même si
forcément ça des nerfs d'un côté qu'il
fasse payer pour avoir en quelque sorte
le pur pour avoir accès à d'autres
portes du jeu en quelque sorte alors sur
battlefield 3 où il est où le contenu
est gratuit mais du coup il y aura moins
de contenu je pense et encore ils vont
sortir des mapaq à mon avis aussi sur
battlefield 3 donc je pense que que non
ça peut pas jouer un mauvais tour à
modern war iii étant donné que les gens
n'achèteront pas forcément il m'a pas
que ces gens n'ont pas envie et tuent
dans battlefield 3 il y en aura sûrement
aussi de toute façon quelqu'un ne va pas
acheter battlefield 3 pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'il y aura moins de
contenu à payant tu as mode rafale 3 il
achètera parce qu'il a envie de jouer un
gameplay différent parce que c'est plus
axé simulation qu'arcade ses plus grands
c'est plus joli aussi on va pas se
mentir alors et c'est pareil pour
quelqu'un qui va acheter mieux enfin 3
il va pas l'acheter
c'est vrai que dans ce cas ça ne marche
pas puisque c'est là où il ya le plus de
contenu payant alors ça me voilà donc je
pense que non ça ne jouera pas de
moratoire mozafar 3 ceux qui ne sont pas
contents n'achèteront pas les maps pas
qu'ils ne prendront pas que d'élite tous
simplement
donc je pense que non ça pourra
strictement pas joué de mauvais tours de
la fin 3 à mon avis les gens ne
choisissent pas leur jeu selon le
contenu payant plus du jeu voilà mais
plutôt selon le gameplay et les
sensations qu'on veut avoir en fonction
du jeu choisi voilà alors est-ce que ça
peut jouer un mauvais tour à call of
duty qui fait tout payé bien moi je
dirais que oui et non tout simplement
parce que je vais essayer de peaufiner
que ça tout simplement parce que call of
duty
étant donné qu'ils font vraiment tous
payés ne perdront jamais c'est quasi sûr
ne perdons jamais leurs fans
car elles sont vraiment accro cette call
of duty magnin on peut dire et ben ça
restera toujours un petit peu grave et
donc les gens continueront à jouer le
quelqu'en soit le prix que ça coûte tout
simplement mais c'est vrai que pour
certaines personnes qui sont indécis
tout simplement qui débute dans le jeu
vidéo ou tout simplement qu'ils ont
jamais été trop fps mais qui hésite
entre battlefield et votent les call of
duty c'est vrai que ça peut jouer un
mauvais côté moi je pense à call of duty
pour pour le fait que wave j'ai pas
envie de payer
voilà il ya plein de gens qui disent moi
j'ai pas du tout envie de payer pour ça
c'est bon battlefield - il propose plus
de choses gratuites trois phases sur
battlefield même si c'est pas trop mon
style vénitien
c'est possible donc pour moi à mon avis
ça peut jouer un mauvais tour pour une
certaine partie de personnes et pour
d'autres n'ont donc sur ce bain je
mettrais
je mettrai comme le point battlefield
car on va je sais très bien que les
grands fans de la call of duty magnin
vont rester mais pour moi en général
pour ceux qui débutent et pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas ou qui sont pas
grands fans de fps
je pense que ça peut leur jouer un
mauvais petit côté donc voilà en
conclusion pour moi ce sera manière d'en
faire trois avec je suis un grand fan de
me refaire du donc voilà j'espère que
mes réponses vous ont plu et je vous
invite à bien écouter les autres et
prendre en considération leurs habits 7
et ortec ait eu à tourner
donc merci à cinétique de m'avoir
conviés à ces questions et puis voilà
bah écoutez si vous avez si vous êtes
intéressés pour voir un disque de
battleship assez voir ma chaîne ça me
fera vraiment plaisir et puis je vous
dis à la prochaine et bonjour à tous en
conclusion je dirais je donne encore un
matin sur trois mais c'est moi vos
commentaires faites un tour sur ma
chaîne et je vous dis à la prochaine par
tout le monde
en bref moi personnellement je suis
contre la guerre moderne warfare 3
contre battlefield 3 je trouve ça assez
débile s'offenser ceux d'entre vous qui
font
moi je me bats café 3 et les autres moi
je regarde lafarge 3 je trouve ça enfin
je trouve ça un peu bête dans le sens où
ceux qui veulent un gameplay axé plus
arcade qui vole plus pour faire des
études pour faire des bébés bukit fidh
enfin un gameplay - réalisme et du coup
qui augmente la citation de gameplay fin
qui augmente la jouabilité disons genève
et bâle
prenez-vous zarafa 3 et pour ceux qui
veulent quelque chose qui se rapproche
plus du réalisme qui donc à un peu plus
long fin je veux dire on fait des kings
- souvent il faut que le plus
stratégiquement je vous conseille donc
battlefield 3 voilà comme ça c'est
personnellement c'est ce que je pense
depuis le début je vous conseille à tous
et à tous de penser comme ça à réfléchir
selon le gameplay que vous voulez soit
quelque chose plus proche du réalisme on
fait moins de kills il faut plus
réfléchir
soit quelque chose un peu plus bourrin
oui car c'est quand même un peu plus
bourrin call of duty battlefield va pas
se mentir c'est à vous de choisir ou
aussi on peut le distingué par exemple
par l'intérêt un peu plus ouverts
battlefield 3 ou un terrain plus ferme
et donc on fait plus de kiel souvent où
c'est plus resserrée call of duty c'est
vraiment quelque chose on peut aussi
dire un jeu magnifique et un jeu ou un
magnifique
ca c c'est un peu bête de juger le jeu
juste part les graphismes même si c'est
vrai que ça entraîne les gens à choisir
battlefield 3 souvent à cause de ses
graphismes qui sont vraiment beaux parce
qu'ils ont mis le paquet avec trois buts
deux en tout cas voilà moi je suis
contre cette guerre ce jeu contre ce jeu
on peut dire les avantages de l'un les
avantages de l'autre mais on ne peut pas
dire voilà ça ça défonce à parce que ces
deux jeux complètement différent c'est
juste de fps mais dans en soit c'est
quand même complètement différent donc
je suis contre cette guerre qui n'a
aucun sens messieurs dames enfin bon
voilà s'est excusé j'espère que ce petit
témoignage vous aura plu sur tout le
monde pareil
[Musique]
alors moi en conclusion je dirais tout
simplement
que battlefield 3 et mona en faire trois
s'ouvre égal on va dire en gros en
général donc ce sera un petit point
chacun de conclusion et puis sur se bat
c'est tout ce que j'aurais à dire donc
maintenant comme je vous l'avais promis
en début de la vidéo on va déjà présent
passer aux intervenants je vais vous
laisser le plaisir de les découvrir en
tout cas pour moi et les autres la vidéo
s'arrête là
j'espère qu'elle n'aura pas été pour au
long pour vous qu'elle vous aura appris
quand même beaucoup de choses où vous
aura tout simplement aider voir plus
clair entre ces deux jeux et qui sait
peut-être que l'on vous aurez à
aiguiller dans l'achat d'un des jeux en
tout cas nous avons tous pris un malin
plaisir à faire cette vidéo et moi sur
ce je vous souhaite bon je connais sont
en mouvement et à la prochaine
[Musique]
m
bakou
[Musique]
aïe